the president's upcoming schedule he's
built around a final campaign push for
Republican candidates before the midterm
elections he will hold rallies in
Florida Missouri and West Virginia later
this week this morning President Trump's
campaign is launching a six million
dollar advertising push Brad parts kale
is president Trump's 2020 campaign
manager and is here to talk about the
elections as part of the booking
agreement we agreed to show 30 seconds
of an ad focused on the economy these
numbers they are depressing is growing
even more slowly than we thought things
are starting to change there's more
opportunity and security to invest in
the ones that matter
[Music]
look we can't get distracted from the
biggest issue which are jobs and are
cute but this could all go away if we
don't remember what we came through
[Music]
and choose the right future Brad also
served as the digital director for mr.
Trump's 2016 campaign welcome to the
table Brad thanks for having me here I
got to say this it's very humble for me
to be here growing up watching CBS and
growing up in rural Kansas you know it's
an amazing thing to eventually be
sitting at this table oh we're glad to
have you yeah we're glad you're here
here the president said get out in 2018
because you're voting for me so why is
he not in the end well look right now
this midterms this is about holding the
house and growing our lead in the Senate
the president's not on the ballot but
this is about his agenda and it's about
the America first agenda and what he's
accomplished in two years and this ad
says can't go back it's important to get
out and vote the things that have
changed in the last two years they can
simply go away and we need to get them
vote Republican the ad says that but the
president says and he has some weight in
the political conversation with his
voters he says it's about caravans and
Cavanaugh's which is not about the
economy yeah well it's about everything
things are getting better and there's
still things we have to get done and if
we don't hold the house we don't
increase our lead in the Senate those
changes can't keep coming and to deal
with immigration laws and to deal with
the things and the problems we still
have and to make this country even safer
and better we have to have the
Republicans and party empowered and I
think the president without that you
know the fight turns into obstruction it
seems like he makes your job harder
really economy economy and the added
self says don't get distracted he is
very good at distracting the
conversation from what you're trying
very hard here to keep it all focused on
well look the economy also has to deal
with illegal immigration you know I
think right now as you see it's getting
tougher to get into this country some
ways you're starting to see unemployment
go down and I think what's happening is
you're seeing wages increase and that's
making people's lives better so they're
all tied together to try to put one of
these pieces as a single issue that
somehow separated it's not true look
it's a lot it's difficult in 60 seconds
to try to put every message out there
yeah and it's expensive to buy
advertising even on this channel so what
we want to do as much as possible is for
people to see things were not so good
not that far back but let's get better
but I do think it's interesting the
point that John is raising because that
the president isn't in the ad but he
keeps telling his supporters in 2018 get
out and vote because you're voting for
me that seems to be his
message on the campaign yeah campaigns
there's two different people this also
go to the president's base which I call
the army of Trump he's gonna fight for
them to show up there they are paying
attention there's also a huge batch of
independent voters suburban mothers
there's people out there that might not
be watching the news every day there's
there's people that watch less than 5%
but you know news they're watching Bravo
they're watching the CBS TV shows
they're not watching the news and I
think this commercial is really target
for them if you look at where we're
making the buy it's targeted towards
those people the people that maybe they
aren't quite as connected every day that
really need to think and remember while
things are getting better and this is
about their children it's about them
having a better future
you know if the economy gets better a
lot of other things can work a lot
easier we just show just for our viewers
too and just pointing out we had this
made out that's from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics which is of course government
independent service about the
unemployment rate and if you take a look
at it actually unemployment rate has
been on a steady decline since 2010 that
was before President Trump took office
so does he need to share some of the
credit with his predecessor is he only
responsible look I think the president
has done so many things with
deregulation he's done so many things to
boost the economy the GDP growth is
there you know the occult unemployment
continues to dip but I think the real
thing is is the rising wages that was
just stagnant and we need to keep
increasing wages for people the fact is
some people of 15 years ago we're making
the same amount of money they were today
needed to stop and I think one of the
problems of that was illegal immigration
and I think that the wage increases are
significant and I think that you're
seeing that from a lot of the policies
as president brought we've talked a lot
about social media you were the digital
director in 2016 I remember you telling
60 minutes that you knew Donald Trump
was going to win because of Facebook and
what you saw happening on Facebook how
what about how Facebook is now altering
its algorithms yeah so I get asked this
a lot social media is definitely
changing I mean I think when the left
found out that Facebook and a tool built
by Silicon Valley helped elect President
Trump they weren't very happy and so
they want to do everything they can to
try to prevent conservative voices and I
think that you have multiple platforms I
call the palace
mafia trying to stop that however
there's a lot of things they can't stop
and I think one of the big emerging
technologies is just your cell phone
direct rich media and text messaging and
the things we can do directly through
your phones what is it that Facebook has
done that's gonna make it harder for
Trump to get reelected
you know there's it's hard to pinpoint
on one thing but they have definitely
made changes significantly to the ad
platform one of the things that we did
in the campaign most people know is we
made 5.9 million ads in the campaign
Hillary Clinton only made 66,000 so when
you actually have to onboard 5.9 million
ads on the facebook it's difficult and I
think they want to try to prevent us
from doing that kind of thing again well
Brad you've been called the the secret
weapon I think your wife some of the
best you're thrown into the Superbowl
never played a game and you won and I
guess you're feeling ok about 2020 I
feel good about 2018 and I feel good
about 2020 all right this President's
agenda continues to change this country
for the better and I think you're gonna
keep seeing that and we just can't go
back
we just can't go back to how things work
thank you for address our school for
being here today